the earth is often the place to bury
things you want to hide
out of sight out of mind
a burial site for radioactivity is under
construction at a place in finland
called ankalo which means cavity or pit
when it opens in a few years it will be
the world's first permanent repository
for high-level nuclear waste when a
fifth reactor is hooked to the grid
later this year nuclear energy will
provide more than 40 percent of
finland's electricity it's a carbon-free
energy source but it comes with a
pitfall spent fuel rods of highly
enriched uranium
operators cool the rods off in pools of
water and store them in warehouses in
interim casks but they're vulnerable to
leaks and accidents while they're above
ground
finland will be the first nation to
permanently dispose of spent nuclear
fuel
robots will transfer the rods to giant
copper casks then bury them nearly half
a kilometer below the surface
they must remain safe and dry for at
least 100 000 years
into the next ice age until the
radioactive elements inside decay to
acceptable levels
it's important to keep water from
carrying radio nuclides back to the
surface a dangerous scenario for
ecosystems and human health
so ankalo relies on a series of barriers
to keep the copper cask safe
the first barrier is the rock itself
hard crystalline rocks that have few
pore spaces and are nearly impervious to
water
volciva the finnish waste company
excavating oncolo map the cracks as its
workers dug and built the repository a
method to keep them from becoming
conduits for water a second barrier is
bentonite a water absorbing clay that
will surround the casks and plug the
burial holes
the bentonite will also block microbes
from reaching the casks and speeding up
corrosion processes
finally there's the copper itself
pulsiva says it won't corrode in what
little water there might be at such
depth because it's oxygen free
ankalo is not just a technological tour
de force
it's a model for navigating controversy
in france the united kingdom and sweden
deep nuclear waste repositories have
been delayed or thwarted by public
opposition experts say posiba and the
finnish government were better at
engaging with residents of aorayoki the
town closest to ankalo finnish law gave
the municipality of veto in the sighting
process and the company dangled the
promise of jobs and tax income as well
as funding a new senior center
culture could be another reason for
unclevo's success finns trust scientific
expertise in state institutions like the
nation's nuclear regulator the lack of
state-level politics in finland presents
another advantage
in the united states the department of
energy's long-standing desire to build a
repository at yucca mountain was
thwarted because of antagonism from
nevada politicians to discuss the
legislative draft before you and our
opposition to yucca mountain
sometime around the year 2120 after
ankalo entombed 6 500 tons of waste
all of the access tunnels will be
backfilled and sealed up service
structures will be dismantled no sign of
the repository will remain
but deep underground the copper cask's
vigil will just be beginning
there they'll rest in silence over the
course of millennia as season
temperatures rise and civilizations come
and go
[Music]
you